[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis
it's the 2019 st. Louis norm Congress
where dreams are still alive here in the
penultimate round my name is Ben Simon
I'm here with Grandmaster Alexander
Linderman and wasting no time let's get
to our standings in our Grandmaster norm
division in our Grandmaster norm
division Dennis Borel
sits alone at the top but it is a very
very close tight field we do know that
Justin Wang is still fighting for his
norm his grandmaster norm his very first
ever if he wins this game and tomorrow
the final round he will get that and
also big news about Tata of Abraham Ian
we will talk about in just a bit
and she is in a featured game today here
are the standings for the IM norm
section after seven rounds have been
completed it's Luis Torres and Keaton
Kira at the top the gatekeepers but
they're not really gatekeepers anymore
because no norms can be earned in this
division anymore no ratings thresholds
are attainable this is simply about
who's gonna win this field a
down-and-dirty
traditional 10th player round robin and
speaking of all of the the format here i
want to talk about what exactly is a
norm because Justin Wayne can still earn
one a norm is a performance quantify it
quantifiably well in a tournament that's
what you got to do you got to score a
certain rating in a very strong field
where there are at least three other
players that have the title that you are
seeking so in the top division we have
three grandmasters and Justin Wayne has
to score six and a half points he's at
four and a half right now if he's at six
and a half by the end of the event he
will earn his first Grandmaster norm you
get three of those and you get to a 2500
rating then you become a Grandmaster our
format is as follows 210 player around
Robin's game in 90 with a 30 second
increment the schedule really simple
from here on out the game started three
hours ago tomorrow the games will start
at 11 a.m. Central time that is the
final round we
have playoffs if necessary in the event
of a tie for first please join us in the
YouTube chat I've got it up and active
ready to go okay round eight pairings
let's see them right now this is
happening right now at us chest champs
dot-com this is the Grand Master norm
section we do know that Joel bonala and
Brian Escalante have drawn their game
but the other ones are still in progress
Casa Corley versus Danish Boros JJ a
lemur on D vs. at Brandon Jacobson
Justin Wang vs. Andrew Hong remember
justin is fighting for a win today and
tomorrow but our key matchup in this
division is Jack's Tim Bulli act versus
Tata of Abraham Ian actually shed
Imbruglia has the white pieces in this
event now this is important because if
Tata have wins she will cross the 2400
rating threshold live rating that is and
that means she will be an international
master elect Alex let's take a look at
this very important game yeah and this
has been again a very sharp fighting
game but unfortunately this has gone
really really south for the TF in this
game in this position black is
completely busted because white is
having a very big King side attack
threatening group g6 foul by Luke H 3
and if black were to take here white
takes Queen takes e5 threatening Queen
h8 mate and if fruit takes f3 we have
check followed by check and and winning
the Queen would mate in short order and
black would have to try Queen g7 button
after rook the xf8 black will lose this
night and then would you know will
probably lose more material soon after
that
so black unfortunately for the TF is
completely completely losing I don't
even see a practical chance for black in
this position and yeah and for
unfortunately I'm afraid this this 2400
quest will have to wait until next
tournament she definitely had chances
even a few moves earlier yeah right
before we took the air
in this exact position black absolutely
had to play knight c6 it was a must she
had to get that Knight into the game
that night on b8 which was doing
absolutely nothing had to go in the game
now the chief was probably afraid of
this and then of Queen takes h6 rook
takes h6 and it looks like why did block
block is just losing but black here has
an incredible incredible continuation
Queens xf3 check double exclam and after
it takes or King takes double exclam 'if
I've followed by roof takes h6 and black
is totally back in the game but this
would have been very hard to see
especially when you don't know there's a
saving resource because this position
looks like it was completely lost for
black and there was this one desperate
chance but unfortunately she didn't find
it and now she's really staring at a
loss interestingly enough I think jack
also was thinking he is completely
winning here after queen g4 also
probably missing this deep idea whereas
Queen c5 probably would have you know
just you know been winning in a much
more simpler matter in this position but
of course such a hidden chances very
hard to find but let's see where exactly
it went wrong for ty TF earlier in the
game so this was a Queen's Indian a
relatively solid line and this Bishop II
one move I think I remember it was
either Aronian or dink
I remember at some point played this and
it was like a relatively fresh new idea
and I think it was against someone like
report maybe
and I remember white you know got a very
good position there and black took here
and played Bishop before which is a very
natural continuation it's possible that
there are other moves that are critical
like d5 or c5 but I'm not a big expert
on exactly how the theory goes here but
it looks like white just very got a very
comfortable position out of the opening
putting the Queen here on d6 and you
know here I think that you know position
is still fighting but of course it's a
bit unpleasant you know white will go 95
you know 497 is quite weak
so black naturally tries to take
can be to to at least suffer for
something but now White has a lot of
practical initiative Bishop C 695 we've
seen you know yesterday I touch of
defend an incredibly difficult position
against a lemur annular where lemur Andy
had a lot of initiative a lot of play
for his two pawns but the chief was able
to find a lot of very accurate moves but
in this game maybe it was a little bit
harder to play even harder to play than
the last time
like maybe here a five deserved
attention to bring the rook in the game
or something that you have took on a two
why took on c5 now black played a five
still might be within fine for black but
it's already getting a little bit
dangerous H for a for h5 h6 you know
otherwise if white gets h6 in the dark
squares will be looming very very weak
for black h6g for but now unfortunately
for that CF this is a very dangerous
hook and Queen B - like maybe Queen c2
was somehow better tempering the rook
and trying to push the pawn as far as
possible but again this is such a hard
position to play from practical
standpoint of view and why just build up
this huge initiative and yeah this is
already probably just a tough position
so this was one of these games where you
know it's just the opening kind of went
wrong and and then you know a little bit
wrong white had a lot of initiative and
why just had a practical advantage and
this was one of these games were the GM
just flexes his muscles and really shows
you know very good preparation very good
form you know jack has been playing very
well in this tournament and he's doing
so in this game as well very well
yeah Tata has had a really good
performance in this event so so far and
it's not over I mean we still have
tomorrow but it looks like that
threshold dream is is just about up in
smoke but let's see our I am norm
pairings right now this is happening
once again at us chess champs calm two
of the games have finished Keaton Kyra
and Ezra chambers have drawn so now
Keaton as it is at six points
live scoreboard and we know that Eric
Rosen with the black pieces has defeated
Kenta chiku rate' we may have Eric in
here in just a bit for an interview it I
don't know that the those pairings are
100% correct but in this division what
we do have today is Luis Torres versus
Gauri Shankar that is a really key
matchup Erin Griffin ski versus Rochelle
Wu and Peter G inaros versus Aaron
Jacobson but yeah like I said this is
the key matchup because we have ranks
number two and Gauri Shankar is tied for
third place right now so this is gonna
be a really big potential game here in
the leaderboard let's take a look at
Lance at this game Alex yeah so here we
have a very complex game materially why
it has an extra exchange rook for Bishop
but Black has one two three four one two
three four three four okay so Black has
two points for the exchange and also
very active bishops so it does seem like
blacks should be fine however white also
has a lot of play with moves like rookie
seven putting pressure enough seven so
it's just a very highly dynamic position
probably roughly equal so let's see how
we came to this position so it was
another Queen's Indian this time white
played the a3 line which is also
relatively popular to this the idea of
that move is to discourage Bishop before
and we're following the line which is
you know relatively popular I've
actually played this myself I think a
few times this Queen a4 check line
trying to take and just trying to play
for a small edge you know trying to play
the structure where the bishop on b7 is
a little bit restricted and you know I
think positions should be equal but you
know black has white maybe has slightly
easier game than black and you know
there's been a lot of maneuverings going
on in this game probably you know it's
not clear who who has a manoeuvered
better in this game it's a very subtle
position and this is where
white went for this very double-edged
move he went for the movie for what idea
winning that exchange arguably though it
might have been more accurate to first
just not get greedy with the material
but just take on c6 and then play four
and play 45 and then it looks like white
has quite a big bit of a pool here
but perhaps white was thinking black
cannot take on d5 and after all we're
winning the exchange but in fact black
so deeper black saw that after this he's
winning two points he's getting a very
strong Bishop here on c4 and suddenly it
might even be black who has better
practical chances and it's ready up to
white to really neutralize you know
blacks initiative because otherwise
black will play moves like 95 h6
threatening 93 Knight of three and
before you know it
black can develop a very big attack so
white has to be very very alert in this
position and I would say black has a
practical advantage in this position all
right Gouri Shankar in case anybody's
curious he just needs to make the 2400
threshold to get a norm but it won't
happen with this event it is
mathematically now impossible okay now
that we've glanced at our key matchups
let's take a quick look at the prize
funds for this event we have a $9,000
prize fund for our top group with $2,000
going to our champion and in the I am
norm group a grand total of $6,000 is on
the line and $1,200 of that will go to
the champion of the I am group and
that's what they're all fighting for
right now no norms are possible in that
group by the way we have a really
awesome chat today I want to thank you
for joining us Michael and Pena it says
why is it called norm Congress if even
at least one norm is not guaranteed Alex
getting a norm is not easy it's not easy
at all
well the normal Congress it's called
because there's a chance to get the norm
right but just because there's a chance
doesn't mean you know you're guaranteed
to get it right it's just there
available if you're gonna play well if
you're gonna win game
you will guaranteed to get the lure it's
also very hard to organize a tournament
with the strict qualifications that the
World Chess Federation is set in place
to make it to make dorms available right
here so that is why this this tournament
is tailor-made for the situation but
you've got to make it happen you've got
to earn it you still gotta play well you
know no one there's no oh there's no
avoiding that ever yeah so with that
said let's maybe take a look at how our
you know Jared how Justin Wang is doing
because he's the only one with the
chance for a norm and unfortunately for
for all of youa Justin when friends this
game is really going downhill for him
because in this position he is down I
think well he's technically not down
material but black has ideas like rookie
to and you can see this 493 at some
point will it become a very big nuisance
the bishop on d7 can take any for any
moment winning potential for some points
the pawn on g7 all the does shields
blacks King and unfortunately for white
he's just completely lost in this
position after move like rookie to check
so somehow something went wrong for him
in this game this was actually a
sveshnikov which has been popularized by
as we all know by Magnus Carlsen in the
recent world championship match against
Bobby Khurana and here white went for
align Queen h5 it looks like white might
be doing well here in the beginning
white went for a very concrete line here
the idea being that sacking a piece but
we're getting it back because of the
made threats but you know position is
still unclear because black has
compensation and the pawn is shielding
blacks King and black has a lot of peace
activist and this is where it looks like
you know the game started going downhill
here because I think as far as I know
for white in the sveshnikov White's main
problem is usually the knight on a three
it's usually not doing very much once
the pawns on b5 so why not just bring it
to C - and then e3 and just try to get
that night in the game I think that
might be maybe somewhat logical or maybe
another move my
although maybe an actual night now that
I look at night c2 might be met with
some night of three and after takes
maybe there's some rookie five so
actually maybe Justin's right about
playing finish three first
prophylactically move but after obviate
now I think maybe somehow to try to get
night see to it but b3 was played Roxy
eight Roxy one before and now Knight has
to go passive a bit there should be
seven Ruby 196 and Queen III so here
maybe there was a chance to place a move
like Queen d7 I know it looks risky
moving the Queen away from the defense
but maybe trying to threaten a few
things I don't know I mean the game is
very complex I would say black has a
practical advantage because again he has
initiative for material and it was one
of these games which just was hard for
white to play has to play very very
precisely and yeah maybe if it's time
for a three trying to just undermine
this you know nice construction for
block but you play Queen d2 room the3
and after ninety three takes takes
unfortunately he cannot take here
because 74 and the bishop opens up and
there are problems on this log diagonal
so he played Queen a for trying to get
the Queen's off the board but now it's
just kind of downhill from here notice
that you cannot even take the pollen g3
because of this very nice tactic t4
takes and then rook takes c3 the idea
being meeting this with the mate so
white plate of three but now that opens
up the three square for the rook and
then there's been some more molex pardon
me I understand the International Master
Eric Rosen is ready to be interviewed so
I'll bow out and he'll be in in just a
moment sounds good so so yeah there's
been some more updates on this game
actually rook c2 was played and then
after a5 still looks very bleak for for
white after Knight moves rook c3 will
play and that will be you know probably
very tough and remember white needs to
win to get as norm so looks very
unlikely for white to win a game like
that so with that said
with this update let's bring us the game
of Eric Rosen who was you know one of
the quick winners of today's round and
he beat actually determines top seed
today she kurata Kenta in a very nice
game it was a name so Indian with the
best face six line with very ambitious
line that I've played at some point
myself I know that there's also move
night of four but when IG three is
pretty solid Bishop d3 d5 and I think
already here black has no problems
because he achieved his main goal that
black is aiming for traded off his light
square bishop which is normally a
problem for black and many openings and
now after rook e8 of three c5 it seems
like you know black has control over the
game and especially after c4 gaining
space on the Queen side it looks like
black kind of took it from there
Knight found himself very comfortable in
h5 and and then black won a relatively
smooth game from there on so without
further ado we have Eric with us here
Eric thanks for coming so how do you
feel about this game I think it was a
very nicely played game by you yeah I
think it was it was smooth kind of a
feel good game and I mean with black it
doesn't happen so often where I feel
like things went my way from very early
on yes especially against quite a good
player yeah he seems to be in bad form
of the stern but still very capable
player I remember he threw me with black
in a tournament so very capable player
for sure so where do you feel like at
what moment where did you feel like you
were starting to already get a
comfortable position
I mean first I want to say that I I had
a little bit of trouble preparing for
him because he plays g4 like very
consistently and I was looking at his
games and he's got so many games where
he just destroys his opponents with with
t4 so I wanted to play something like
very solidly and something which I
haven't he just finds some line which I
haven't
maybe played so often so I decided to
play this line in the nihms oh yeah III
b6 it's actually a line isolated quite a
lot when I was younger yeah III b6
because I've never played b6 in this
position I usually Castle I think that's
a d5
that's what I usually do yeah but I
thought this was had some interesting
nuances and after night g2 Bishop a6 and
then white has to make a decision how to
deal with the c4 pawn yeah I think the
most common is a3 and then you know you
there Bishop takes c3 or Bishop e7 and
if there should be seven there's some
sharp line Latta for remember my coach
wanna Georgie won a very nice game yeah
I was planning to just take on c3 play
d5 and then just keep it yeah that's
pretty solid but I'm guessing that you
know maybe white is tad better but you
know maybe it's easier for black to
place so haven't studied out in depth
sure but yeah 93 here I think that black
already gets very comfortable game right
I just want to show like one funny line
I was referring because I was looking at
night g3 before the game and one idea
with 93 is that white wants to play me
for yes so if we imagine after castling
efore I would play Knight to c6 and then
things can get very wild like if if 'if
I've I have 98 and then like ideas at
6:00 yeah you're gonna undermine the
space the thing is white is not able to
gain space and be very comfortable
because he's kind of behind in
development here so that's why this kind
of stuff probably will backfire or at
least be comfortable for black and then
there's interesting idea for white here
to play Bishop d3 mysterious awesome ID
for pawn and then 1964 and then idea
Queen a well Quinn f4 I see so try to
account double attack these bishops and
I was preparing this with stockfish
before the game and it's just so wild
because buck can actually justify this
line by playing Bishop a5 mm-hmm
b4 and then d5 this is insane position
yeah absolutely yeah it's really
anyone's game
yeah a lock will be down a piece but
there's tons of compensations yeah and
one thing I don't think I mentioned to
you in the previous interview but I'm
I'm recording all my preparation
sessions and I'm planning to post them
to YouTube after the tournament so
people can connect those that there's
been some interesting like computer
analysis I've done but haven't gotten
beat having gone to show like maybe I
should check it out myself maybe I'll
even if you play this line is black yeah
thing there - well you never know I can
at some point I can always play
something for the first time right so
true ideas are always welcoming so yeah
if you're a strong player or even you
know an amateur player that make sure
you check out Eric's preparation
sessions you can learn a lot of
interesting things
yeah but here it looks like why didn't
play the most critical line and now
blocks moves are just very natural
you're playing 4 C 5 C forint you know
naturally you know he wants to play for
so you don't let him get that in in
comfortably so I was happy to like that
the structure is like f3 like usually
the main idea with f3 is 2 pi e 4 but
it's so difficult for white to actually
making for work because I have a lot of
pieces controlling me for and also a lot
of pressure on d4 yeah here maybe white
should try to play a 3-wood the idea of
take stakes then try to get e4 and then
this should be 2 and this actually
reminds us of like you know this famous
structure where I think in 1938 like
what we I mean but when you kappa blanka
right yes so this kind of thing would
maybe me more testing because after a3 I
think I can take on d4 take on d4 yeah
then maybe 95 or something or around or
even or even just takes bishop takes and
then you can take with the Queen and
well white would never be worse here at
least you get rid of the c4 idea and
okay here you can go Queen d1 and you're
playing 44 it just seems like Nia 92 was
the step in the wrong direction because
then after this actually maybe it was
make sense to play c4 first because
after this if he played b3 maybe he's
still kind of equal ish
you didn't see b3 in the game that makes
sense also b3 here was maybe somewhat
possible but after this yeah he probably
should go be 3 because a3 is kind of
just asking for c4 to be played it's the
move you want to play anyway and now
it's pretty much even b3 becomes less
effective because after b5 he loses a
tempo so a3 just really seems to be out
of place here and ever since you know
this was an interesting new ones Bishop
d6 inducing this and going with chef 8
they'll try to get you 6 it's like it
loses time but I thought eventually
neither knife I will have to you're
gaining climb actually because
eventually g6 95 you want to play anyway
it's happens and now you played Knight
c3 also possibly not the best move maybe
he should try to go for you for right
away or or even move like this no sorry
maybe you should just go back and try to
at some point still play for anything
when you playing out of 5 you you want
to justify over g4 yeah but Knight c3
kind of seems a bit imprecise maybe
maybe g6 first is also possible to not
let him even get c4 right but I mean
even the way you played it looks like
you know you always were very much in
control over the position and sure he
could have defended better but overall
you put your pieces in good moment
coming up I think f4 was just a
positional mistake yeah 4 was pretty bad
yeah because now he never gets he
foreign under good circumstances this
mission becomes about he's putting all
the pawns in the dark squares it's like
one of these pictures position because
he literally he has a dark square bishop
and put all the pawns on the dark
squares so it's something that you
literally should not do in a chess game
so I think you play that for with some
interesting intention to eventually play
Queen f3 and then g4 f5 mm-hmm and I did
have to find the right approach because
okay the actually an interesting moment
after rook e7 I think he originally
wanted to take on d5 but the night right
but this walks into rookie 4 yeah
cutting off the defense of the Queen and
then only in the e3 pawn X yeah well the
point is the lesson here is like when
you're playing like in a very anti
positional way which are for is you
better make sure
tactics work in your favor because
otherwise it's like you get positionally
bankrupt so it's like yeah the lesson to
all of you is if you're going to go for
a concrete line which is positionally
skeptical and that's what I teach all my
students you really got to make sure
tactically it will work out very true
so and in this case it's 91 I think this
is very important position to figure out
how to make progress with black because
when he initially played 91 I didn't
really see a way to improve because it
seems like my pieces are fully optimized
and then I was very happy with the idea
I ended up finding I initially wanted to
play Bishop takes d4 right away right
away but it gets a little bit murky
after pawn takes Knight takes Queen g4
and yeah let's say rookie - yeah rookie
- 9 F - yeah maybe it's somehow good for
black d4 yeah it looks like it should
still be a deep one is rolling it looks
like it should still be good but
certainly there's nothing wrong with
Queen D so 27 idea is to play Bishop
takes d4 next move and then he's not
gonna have Queen g4 right yeah that was
a good nuance Ian I mean from a
practical standpoint of view I think
this was much stronger anyway it still
takes him one more move to prepare g4
cuz not each workshop exactly g4 so all
of your of yours
yeah g4 is met by this so if I drag each
one I think just preparing g4 hope -
hope - for a miracle that he does get
you four then somehow Queen h3 but of
course Bishop takes d4 came you don't
need to be asked twice and then you know
takes twin c3 Knight b3 rugby one Queen
a5 yeah and their work is like
essentially trapped on b1
yeah and that's Queen a5 is another good
move to trap the rook and take away this
square and there's so many resources for
black with 2 and d4 always looming yeah
and then from there it's like just this
is forcemeat force made
yep so congratulations the very nice
games now you're guaranteed to finish on
the plus score how would you assess your
tournament so far I mean for the most
part I think it's been solid with my
exception of my game yesterday against
Aaron I mean he played a pretty good
game despite having a rough tournaments
and okay there's still one more game so
I'm so going to try and stay focus and
you're gonna be white right who do you
have less strong I'll be playing Keaton
in the last round also actually this
tournament
yeah because let's with that said let's
take a look at what weather what are the
standings because we last time I checked
ah so Luis Carlos is a drop so actually
you can still win the tournament if you
beat Keaton because wait but Keaton is
eaten as one point ahead of you I
thought you said you have five and
you're gonna be white so this is
actually your opportunity to and Luis
Torres just finished in a draw breaking
news against coercion car in a very
sharp fighting position so that means
you know Taurus you know would need to
win to overtake you in case you win so
you actually still have a realistic
chance you have kind of things for the
most part in your control so still very
much something to play for you can even
still may win determine theoretically so
I wish you you're putting more pressure
on a hand so I wish you best of luck
link investor preparation tomorrow I
have another place for me uh well just
do it the best you can and you know and
try to enjoy the game and you know see
what happens that's good advice
alright Eric thanks for coming as usual
and and now let's take a look at what
exactly happen in this Torres game so
this was a game there greets are drawn
but the position is still very much
fighting game any anything can go and
the guy Yuri offered the draw here I
don't know what the time station was but
in this position black is the one who is
clearly better because of the things
I've mentioned before I think black has
two points for the exchange which is
material at least as good as they
exchange but he also has a very strong
porn past porn potential number
active pieces and I mean to me it looks
like black has nothing to risk and in
this position maybe it was better for
white to play rookie 795 and even give
back to the exchange but of course it
was very hard to play like this playing
rugby sevens like computer has client
after Queen is 795 black offer the draw
which I'm sure
Lewis was very very happy to to accept
it so so now what do we have so as we've
discussed before we have so now let's
see okay so now we have do you like to
be called Jack or you beginning come in
it's up to you okay so I know we have so
you've gained you just won the game
against that's EF so congratulations
have gained it we were looking at this
game in studio it looked like an
excellent game so how do you feel about
this game yeah actually I mean the game
will event pretty well so I think it's
one of the best games I've ever played
yeah it also looked very good I mean it
looked like you had initiative and I
couldn't even spot any any real mistake
in this game what do you think was the
critical moment that then where did it
go wrong for her where did she make a
mistake was it just in the opening or
was it somewhere later I'm not sure
about the opening but then at some point
she started moving her pong a five-way
for my business was a bit slow so what
do you think maybe she should have done
instead of a five here I don't know
maybe Queen a six Queen a six
yeah and then what idea of maybe rook c8
yeah maybe
mm-hmm and then if you go H four still
then maybe even have six or Queen B
seven yeah it's four is too slow here
yeah you have to play rook f3 but then
Queen c8 yeah so this might have been
better maybe better given blood more
defensive chances actually yeah after a
five though it looks like h4 a4 h 5 h 6
g for the position looks in
dangerous for black maybe Quincy to us a
try what would you do with Quincy Quincy
- I would I'm not sure but I would
probably go room 323 rook 1 G 3 and then
yeah maybe a queen bee 1 and just try to
go for a quick I 3 I mean it still looks
very dangerous but maybe somehow
miraculously could this somehow hold I
don't believe but of course it's very
hard to place something like that but it
looks like after queen bee to g5 r it's
already getting more more difficult to
defend takes h6 yeah and there was this
one interesting critical moment I hear
you played very well but in this
position Quincy five was you know
completely crushing but after Queen g4
black actually had a very incredible
resource here that I'm not sure if you
saw that during game but 96 okay I
thought 96 Queen takes c6 rock h-60 and
it looks like it's completely winning
but black has an incredible resource
here Queen takes of three a double
exclam and amazingly after u5 she still
kind of survives ya know that's a very
hard move to see I mean they're very
very deep of course so that was like a
very hidden chance for her still in the
very end but once she played of 6 from
this point on of course this is very
simple because for King it just gets
very badly at octant
but here it was a very interesting
moment if instead of footage for a
player which is three mm-hmm oh you mean
here yeah but then Queen D 494 yes if I
go Queen B 7 and take only six it's
perpetual after Queen e4 oh yeah she has
this Queen h7 check mm-hmm yeah I almost
play the rock just three but after we
just three it's already hard to win yeah
yeah I cannot take the rook yeah yeah
that was so that's why you know you have
to always fight til then you have to
always look for chances yeah especially
when the Queen's on the board there
something can still happen but yeah oh
gosh for of course was very precise I
was a very good calculation by you and
then of course now she resigned because
she's
they're getting made or losing the Queen
yeah so yeah this is a this is a great
game for you our congratulations and a
wonderful win so this sets you up for a
very exciting last round so now we've
just updated looks like Dennis Boras
Porsche has once that means he's still
gonna be half point ahead of you but
still definitely real chances for you in
the going to the last round who is your
opponent in the last round my opponent
is Andrew Hong Oh Andrew Hong so you
know he just you know drew a game
against Justin Wang
just ending Justin's chances for his
norm but of course young player very
dangerous but also fighting players so
should give you some chances maybe so
you know I wish you best of luck in the
last round hopefully making the
tournament more exciting you know and
maybe a chance for a playoff and maybe
even with perfect situation maybe even
winning outright but in any event you
know you know you'll I'm sure you'll do
your best I'm not gonna ask you what
your strategy is because I don't want
you to give away anything but you know
I'll let you go and prepare know thanks
a lot for coming thank you
congratulations again
thank you alright so with that said
let's update you on some breaking news
Dennis Boros as we just look did indeed
win the game against Casa Corley now
interestingly enough it looks like you
know it was maybe expected because Casa
has been really having a very rough
event here and dennis has been in great
form but the thing is though it's always
hard to win on demand with black and in
fact earlier in the game Casa had a
serious advantage because Dennis took
some risks in the opening and this is
the kind of structure that I remember is
usually the one where black tries to
play for a win kind of keeping all the
pawns and pieces on the board and but
we're gonna take a look at this game
later because right now we're gonna take
a look at Rochelle who's game who won
her first game of the tournament a very
nice game against Aaron Grove in ski
and we have Rachelle in the studio with
us today so Rachelle congratulations
great game how do you feel about this
game I feel I got really lucky with a
bunch of small tactics I he miss mm-hmm
so what do you think were some main
critical moments it was obviously long
games so we're not gonna be able to go
through all of it so what do you think
were the main moments when you think he
missed something probably when he plays
like Queen III o
we night 3 so move 37 Queen I 3 so you
think Queen d2 was better or what do you
think was better for him in this
position something like we need to but
the thing is like we need three kind of
like forgets about the e4 pawn mm-hmm so
after Bishop d6 suddenly yeah this what
he probably missed was after up takes d6
suddenly there's gonna be some perpetual
and then some Queen takes e4 right so
the line would go like this here King
edge 3 and then Queen a five and if King
g2 queenie for perpetual and mg3 rook
III still no way to avoid perpetual in
fact white maybe has to be careful not
to get made it here so that was a very
subtle move though Bishop d6 was a very
alert move catching a very catching him
off guard and suddenly his pawn on e4 is
weak so that's just a lesson for all of
you like whenever you decentralize the
Queen you have to always watch out for
some tactics like that
so after Bishop d6 let's see what
happened Queen B 2 root X t4 already you
recovered the poor and now the game
keeps going you know it still looks like
you know white should not be in any
danger it should be a draw but your
opponent was still ambitiously trying to
kind of play for a win probably and and
then you know the game keeps going keeps
going and still nothing much is
happening and then suddenly he lashed
out with this rook takes f5 so what do
you think he missed when he went for
this tactic I think he just missed f5
you think he missed the 5 so maybe
Bishop before was already kind of a
blunder and he missed that after a5
there's Queen c6 King g1 and suddenly
Queen c5 right so he was just yeah it
looked it was one of these positions
where it looked like he can just play
free position all game long but but you
still have to always watch out for
tactics even in a position where it
looks like you have no risk there's
still always risk potentially involved
and in this position you could still go
Queen a4 here actually because after it
takes
there's Queen of fate did you see Queen
of four yes so that would have been
still he would have been fine here
actually but you know sometimes when you
make a blunder it's psychologically very
difficult to recover you feel like
you've made a mistake but it's very
important to just calm down and put it
behind you and like and relax but of
course when you're having a difficult
tournament like Aaron is having it's
much more difficult to do that and then
after this rook takes you for of course
being very precise
now you're just type of piece and from
this point on it looked like you won
very cleanly I mean I'm wondering if you
still house maybe as some drawing
Chancellor's here but yeah that's why I
was hesitant to go into Queen f6 but I
thought there is no way to lose so yeah
there's no way to lose yeah I mean it's
of course very heart endgame so valid
whether it's actually winning or not
maybe this would have been more precise
I mean that's of course requires deep
analysis but yeah it looks like you
should have gone King g3 and you know if
you go bishop g1 he can go h3 and looks
like this extra temple makes a big
difference somehow but you know again
it's a very hard position to play hard
to defend especially when you're winning
all game long
yeah and this was already probably it's
winning well maybe before was still
still a try right because it takes one
sex and then King c4 like very unusual
and then somehow a5 is a threat and if
Bishop d6 king b3 it still might
amazingly enough be somehow a draw but
again a very rich end game certainly a
lot to learn from it and even here
there's maybe some but ok it's he missed
this opportunity and then you you know
eventually got the win
so congratulations on this nice win you
know and again I think that you
definitely deserve it because obviously
you know you will have a couple of games
earlier in the turn
where you were very close to winning in
particular against Eric which kind of
escape from you so now it makes sense
that you know you got a win that maybe
just wise you know a little bit of a
gift but you know you definitely
deserved it because you fought very hard
till then you had a positive approach
and you know now having yourself a very
salt tournament so what are your
thoughts going into the last round
how are you playing in the last from I'm
playing against Peter and I don't know
how it is play tres yeah sounds like a
great approach you'll be white so you
know I wish you best of luck against
Peter and also in your future upper norm
tournaments I'm sure you'll have many
more opportunities ahead of you where
you have a great chance to go foreign
chess I wish you best of luck thanks a
lot for coming here thank you
alright so that was Rochelle who who won
a nice game against Aaron you know it
wasn't pretty maybe earlier but later on
you know it was a very clutch win and we
also have some other results that
happened Peter who rochelle mentioned
her last round opponent did end up
beating aaron jacobson so unfortunately
aaron after his very fast start his
tournament kind of went a bit south
still had a very respectable 50% but of
course not what he was hoping for I'm
sure going into this tournament Keaton
was a draw so we have all games finished
in the I am norm section and then GM
Lawrence section we just spoke with Jack
who did beat against that's EF and we
still have one game going on right now
between a lemur and E and Brandon
Jacobson and this game looks like it's
oh I have no idea who is mating whom in
this position because it looks like both
Kings are in extreme danger but I would
still say more likely white is winning
because white is you know black is in
check and white will always be on move
and you know it looks like you know why
should you know Windows this game
situation here being that there's so
many heavy pieces on the board
if white doesn't check in one time do
you think that the Y could slip up well
of course because black is threatening
mates as well so pretty much you
absolutely must check it right yeah
otherwise you know black will quickly
counter-attack with the checkmate at
once so no you absolutely have to check
and you know but it looks like white
should be able to to deliver mate for
the first time so the I mean why should
be able to you know be the first one to
be able to deliver mate
you know I noticed you mentioned that
all the games in our B group had
finished tomorrow there's going to be
three players who potentially could hit
first place and they're all the IMS you
know so business as usual here but we're
gonna see the best plane tomorrow I mean
especially if there's a playoff so that
could be exciting stuff yeah Eric didn't
even realize that he had still chance
for first probably after his key loss to
Aaron that looked like his chances were
done but it turns out they're not God in
fact they're very real if he just is
able to win with white one game there
they sign the score sheet the game is
over it appears that JJ Ali mirandy has
defeated Brandon Jin yeah and that's you
know they're they both kind of had
difficult tournaments and unfortunately
Brandon it's just been a tough
tournament for him you know a lot of
losses I mean basically he's a very
fighting intriguing player but sometimes
when you're in bad form and you fight
you know you end up having some times
that's off results Alex you know we just
had Rochelle Wu in here and she said
that tomorrow she's cos she's gonna play
chess against Peter Jian Atos and we
have Peter for an interview here so
we'll get him in the studio in just a
moment yes let's see what happened
exactly in Peters game so Peters game
was right here so let's see how we saw
the ending let's see how the the game
started out it started out as a quiet
opening night of three g3 and g4 night
h6 very unusual move water normally
night of six is the more popular but I
have a feeling this was somehow prepared
by black a little bit and a night of
five you know
the different set up white plates
solidly in the beginning so there's not
that much happening and then white
decided to challenge the center looks
like it loses a pawn but of course you
know you get it right back
Knight of six takes takes takes takes
takes and you know it looks like white
has a slight cool here thanks to his
pawn in the center and black has to
still find a way to counter-attack
so c6 Queen b3 Queen b6 and now white
went for this interesting idea
d5 Bishop d7 turkey won and looks like
why it's still kind of pressing and
eventually he was able to build and
build and build his advantage
controlling the file trading Queens and
eventually we saw what happened to white
ended up winning a nice game so Peter
congratulations on a very nice smooth
game yeah how you how do you feel about
this game it's a little bit of a relief
that I've been I lost three games in a
row and I've lost prior to this game
every game with white and so it was just
nice to actually feel like I have the
white pieces for once you know like I
felt like I had an enduring advantage
for most of the game I'm I was obviously
unfamiliar with the way he played in the
opening night h6 and yeah 96 was I'm
just I've even never seen this move
water in this position I've seen the
idea but not in this exact position yeah
so I don't know if what I did seemed
pretty tame but it seemed like I got a
slight advantage anyway like it seemed
like he was a few Tempe behind in
development once I opened the game with
92 and E 4 yeah no I think the way you
played was was logical because if he
consolidates and plays Knight if it
looks like he should be ok but there was
one moment yes I wanted to ask you about
yeah
if he goes instead of Knight of 6 if he
goes III how did you evaluate that um
yeah I actually I thought it was fine
but I thought I thought it would go like
Fe Knight f6 oh I thought you'd probably
castles first right okay and then e e4
maybe a 4 and then maybe five friends
okay Wow so that maybe was an
opportunity for black yeah so I'm not
I'm not exactly sure what was the best
way to play there is also a key one what
idea after night of
maybe to play play the Queen said but
yeah it's for stirring game it's very
hard to decide yeah in my in IO and I
always thought in the event that he ever
ever wants to play something like f5 or
something like that I wanted to leave
eewan open for my night so I could go
91-93 so I didn't want to go rook e1
unless I was sure that I was gonna get
you for it yeah that makes sense yeah
and he maybe could actually consider f5
I mean it looks a little bit artificial
but you know you never know
Rokon e1 is just weird could be like
some kind of a stone wall so yeah if for
looks pretty logical straightforward and
the way it happened you got a very nice
yes here I was yeah here I was pretty
calm I thought I thought I was pretty
comfortable and and I thought I'd played
some reasonable moves here like okay
Bishop f4 sort of obvious but uh I guess
the reason it's obvious is cuz I wanted
to stop a five mm-hmm yeah you know I I
didn't know what else to play I mean uh
I just wanted to stop a five and then
and then c6
I thought Queen b3 was good as well and
then Queen b6 I mean you know it's all
this is sort of anticipated and I didn't
want him to go Bishop e6 so I played d5
yeah do you find that very logical move
actually it's like a prophylactic move
and yeah you know the thing is taking
this doesn't quite equalize because then
you can take exactly it doesn't have the
C pawn and these pawns become doubled
isolate exactly the big difference and
my just hammering the Queen side so it's
I I was very happy with yes d5 shows a
very good understanding of the position
here Bishop d7 yeah you hear I just
build I you know without explanation
just brought my rooks and then actually
offered me a draw after a five but you
know yes as miserable as I been at the
tournament as I've been having it was ya
know you know and that's a great
mentality here because you know
sometimes after three losses in a row
it's very easy to just say okay let's
just you know lick the wounds let's just
cut down on the losses and make sure but
you know no I mean I'm very I very much
admire your fighting spirit you you came
here to play chess you came here to
learn and you wanted the most you can
out of every game and that's what's
gonna help you hopefully propel to
becoming an
even better player thank you so that's
you know absolutely right approach
that's what I would tell all my students
no matter how it goes you have to always
fight now interestingly enough somehow
maybe it was better to play rook easy
one because then in case he goes here I
have been you on the file yeah you have
the rook on the file it's a little bit
counterintuitive yeah but after Ruby one
I'm wondering if you thought say takes
and plays something like a five yeah I
actually I thought that was possible
yeah and then it looks like maybe you
know you're losing a little bit part of
your advantage yeah so this is where
maybe there is some other alternatives
like Bishop e3 or rookie deewan but of
course it's hard to you know yeah
catch every critical moment and yeah he
probably should take on b3 and play a5
take advantage of the fact that the rock
left but now you're just controlling the
D file fully they and from this point on
you know yeah I dislike I think is
because he thought after he took and I
played Bishop face he thought about
playing Bishop e6 which which means to
me he he originally planned Bishop c6
but Bishop c6 Queen c4 I think that's
game over
oh yeah okay but I think even even this
I think has to be unpleasant for for him
some no doubt no doubt
I didn't like the Queen coming to f3
which is why in the game I play Queen d5
after trading everything right so as I
was trying to look for a forced win that
couldn't find one you know if Queens he
says if rook 1 d6 he can take with the
Queen well I've actually I do a lot of
lessons on this team actually he'll
because you know generally speaking the
queen is like the glue in the position
like it keeps the position kind of
together yeah and you know you already
have control over the you know the files
you know and actually your roofs are
better than his rooks or vicious bear in
his rook only the Queen his queen is
kind of the active piece that's good so
it makes perfect sense to trade it off
it again shows very good understanding
of the position and from this point on
you're kind of yeah the reason I played
c5 is I sort of anticipated he would go
rookie 7th and I would play c5
right before right I anticipate he was
gonna go rookie 7 and then and then and
then see fires right yeah yeah there was
also maybe this move in and out for this
yeah just go like that yeah yeah yeah
maybe that was also good but I'm
in any way the way you played was always
pretty good you always maintained a very
big advantage and yeah here I was a
little no this is this is yeah you I
have a stronger move yeah maybe a little
d7 there should be 2 takes King g8 yeah
and then rook takes h7 uh-huh and just
yeah yeah so maybe b3 was a little bit
kind of too safe because at least he
kind of yeah stabilizes a little bit but
still of course you're much better yeah
King f1 I was a little concerned about
counter play with III like rookie a give
me the a pawn then go III and he gets
the rooks in so I was like if I just go
King f1 and to me right now III with f4
my book on the on the fifth-ranked
covers all the breaks right and then
bring the King to e2 and then do
whatever I wanted to do that was my
thought I was just trying to because I
thought of other than King f1 I thought
of other things but I just didn't want
his his look like I can attack the pawn
then I thought he'd go rook d8 right if
I go rookie v broker d4 yeah rook e8
let's say well okay it you couldn't okay
so it's a little concern with these III
possibilities what if you go king of one
here okay so then you still plays a fine
yeah and if you take this then III I
just thought why why allow him to well
you win up one though yeah that's true
that's true so there's there is
something to be said about that because
here maybe yeah yeah after a five gimme
two at least you know you don't win the
pawn so that's but of course it's still
like a very pleasant edge yeah but you
know what you should try to play rook f3
probably uh-huh and just get the rook
over well go a for maybe hey go away for
and go rooks e3 so he kinda actually
anyway has to counter played it was like
yeah so you know that was his chance
certainly yeah so h5 was played roof d7
yeah and then we have rookie six that
was a good idea trading is active one
yeah yeah and from this point on you I
think I did okay from this point on you
played very well yes yeah and you traded
room rooks maybe hoping for you know
miracle in the ponen game but I got a
little I got a little scared
this race going on because my king was
so far away yeah King b5 King takes d5
actually yes would have been a big
mistake very tempting to do that but
actually yeah that that whenever I
played h4 I was trying to figure out
like how do I make it his move so that
he has to go King d7 and I'm up a tempo
on this line yeah that was probably
hoping for that's what you thought maybe
there's a little bit of a chance but of
course if he goes there you just come in
there yeah yeah then I win this one and
he's way behind in the race yeah
so if five King here and there now it's
easily it all leads to that same
position same position but this time
you're a couple of Tempe and yeah yeah
okay yeah you still had one trick I
guess you weren't you women yeah but
yeah yeah that was that was nice yeah so
it's a very instructive game very nice
nicely played maybe at times and then
you got a little bit too careful and
giving him anyway counter play with a
five but in any event you know a win is
a win it was a very nice win for you
nethertheless especially coming off of
three losses so what is your score right
now three three out of eight yeah you
know still have a chance to do it
respectable score if you win the last
game and yeah try to just finish strong
yeah you know I really like your
fighting spirit and most importantly
it's not about how you score here it's
about how many good lessons you take
from this tournament to play better next
tournament and get better in the long
run that's the way I always look at it
and thanks a lot for coming here and I
wish you best of luck thank you for the
next game and your future encounters
thank you thank you Alex thanks for
coming okay so so now we're gonna take a
look at what happened in the Dennis
Boris's game and so as we already know
he won the game but we didn't really
check deeply on what happened so we kind
of briefly checked in the opening where
you know black played an ambitious
opening with the risk of getting a worse
position and of course white is better
here thanks to his space advantage and
as of right now Casa is kind of
controlling the game but
you know later something was kind of
slipping away from from white in this
position
I mean maybe white somewhere here should
find a better plan and but here I feel
like once you start trading off pieces
you know then already Black has not too
much to worry about getting in a five
and space advantage isn't as much felt
without pieces on the board and black
still keeps his Bishop and now we have
the man himself
Denis burrows with us to explain to us
the subtleties of this very interesting
complex game
so Dennis congratulations on another
very nice win you know very I know your
opponent was having a rough tournament
but still it's very hard to do win on
demand with black as you know we very
well know so what was your approach
going into this game I saw you decided
to play a very double-edged opening so
well yeah like I felt that this is a
very interesting position with lots of
fighting chances I thought I should give
it a go yeah and what was it Magnus who
inspired you a little bit of film's win
against Vincent crime I mean it reminded
jog my memory but actually I think I've
played this before that no I've seen
this structure and some guy called me
Hotel played this one like so yeah it
makes sense so try to follow him yes so
very good advice to everybody yeah now
here I as far as I know I've usually
been accustomed to seeing a line like h3
yeah that was consider like kind of old
fear in and rook e8 and then even
sometimes rook takes e3 or something or
B yeah looks like c3 I saw some more
savage games there but I'm not sure I
think what should be better there but
also after castles I thought I've always
seen this but maybe this is kind of too
Jewish and so easy to play for white
yeah I felt that if I go for this even
though this is the principled way of
playing it's not necessarily like is not
hoping for much actually I've seen
Wesley
to play this in like a crucial World Cup
match with black when he had to win yes
and he went for a takes he takes Bishop
g4 and he had to suffer oh that was
against England yes right yeah yeah I
remember that yeah yes and so I think 96
is more practical 96 is more practical
yeah very much so
so you were pretty much going through
this game kind of like really trying to
trying to win well we're definitely
looking for a fighting position yeah
that makes sense yes so 97 rookie won
and now he five so definitely you know
to all of you who who are following a
good idea if you want to try to play for
a win is to try to keep the bone
structure locked keep as many pieces on
the board as possible because in these
kind of positions the engine doesn't
understand positions would eight pawns
each side as well and they're like much
harder to prepare and it's like they're
very very subtle so it's one of these
things where whoever understands the
structure better will probably play
better so even if it might be
objectively better for white it's still
a hard position to place so where did
you feel like white was starting to go
wrong I think might be five was a little
strange 95 so what would you what do you
think white should have done instead by
definitely so he was looking for some
counter play on the Queen side and I
think that's correct
but Knight beef I was actually blocking
the rook the whole be diagonal I mean
the line and also even any Queen a4
ideas don't make sense anymore after
night b5 so what do you think why should
have done here maybe instead well maybe
even Bishop d2 subdue to just kind of
playing for a normal development and
then night after night of for maybe
Bishop f1 yeah yeah just kind of keeping
the tension just playing the position
the way he did but without 95 yes okay
but 95 of course should not be a losing
move King h8 975 Queen d7 Bishop C 2 F 6
it still looks like white is sort of in
control he just you know maybe 95 wasn't
the best move King edge to in fact
instead of Queen e7 I still considered
neither
maybe that's better night a for first
right and I also have like cute little
night g2 tricks yeah yeah maybe not
always although if you take and then go
Queen d2 maybe yeah the question is if
after g5 work that looks very ugly I
admit that
if I though there are some what some
shows like this 5 mm yeah after this
there's even like stuff like this this
did look dangerous yeah no so I think
you played fine you know keeping the
tension and and now maybe white should
try something like Quincy one just do
something about that night right so just
you know give you a question right if
you either you go g5 or do something
else I'm not I'm not sure I'm actually
asking you what do you think about g5
here I was concerned I heavily
considering it and I wasn't happy about
it but I thought what else can you do
though exactly yeah
so I think Queen c2 what the very least
should have been played because it's
like annoying practical move right you
know give you an annoying question you
have to now you know make a decision and
make a difficult decision
should you play g5 creating you know a
weakness or do something else but then I
think why should never be worse because
he can come the night here rook h1 king
g1 and your bishop is kind of
restrictive Saul would still take white
in a heartbeat here yeah I would say
that why there's definitely four choice
but I can probably go with h5 and
prepare g4 I'm not saying yeah I'm not
well that's why you know this plan
probably is quite like you know but yeah
that's that was very very deep of course
but Quincey want any kind of attacking
move like mosquito bite always has to be
considered yeah but Knight g1 is kind of
defensive you know Queen g7 rugby 397
and now takes kind of releases the
tension maybe wasn't as best and then
Knight 67 probably also not so good
because the knight on c7 is kind of
restricted so maybe Knight c3 was better
to use this Knight more so for defense
sometimes but he went here and now it
looks like it's already you're
completely fine but at one moment did
you feel like here you can really
win this game like you were much better
um I was getting very confident when
I've got this position because I kind of
saw from games and some experience that
it's very hard to break through in this
position with white yeah and then black
has the practical advantage you know the
bishop on seed controls a lot of squares
of course you know that was very
instructive not to trade this off
because then you can even deal with the
past one here Bishop on c8 is not only a
great defender of some key squares but
it also is potentially a very important
Italian piece as we've seen later now I
think one thing that was critical in
this game is this Bishop f6 Bishop h4
maneuver you think we kind of glossed
through yes for Bishop d1 yes and then
annoying Bishop f6 because my bishop is
really bad especially in these Kings
Indian structures and after I managed to
bring it to h4 it already is like an
attacking piece very good point yeah
activating your least active piece very
instructive lesson so you know after
this it looks like yeah now you're
definitely four choice and g4 your
attack comes very natural and already
here it looks like you know very hard to
play I mean and Quincy three looks like
was his big mistake I think if he still
runs away with King do you want King c2
probably around the equals it's still
around equal but Queen c3 was a horrible
mistake which kind of just does not in
time he'll lets you do too many things
to him
I mean Queen g6 is strong and I guess he
was kind of hoping that Bishop takes F
force work but obviously there's G takes
f three yeah yeah exactly yeah
and so just kind of being a ban in bad
form unfortunately but here it looks
like you should have gone Bishop g4 23
and and then only rotation because when
you played rock h5 I think you did have
a some chances still for example Bishop
goes back to a4 from the la-la-land
beat 5 where it doesn't do anything and
then this comes to d1 yeah and then
after Bishop g4 then there's still some
bishop eh
so but I mean let's be honest
that Bishop a for Bishop ei that's some
genius idea
yeah that's going back now I'm going
forward yeah that's that's that's that's
that's true that's true but I mean it
just goes to show why Bishop g4 was
better getting the Queen out of there
right away just to get rid of the Bishop
e8 idea once and for all and then
rotates five so that was probably your
only little blemish on the otherwise
wonderful wonderful game and this
endgame is it probably lost it might
close there might be some might be a
little bit of a chance yeah notice how
Bishop d3 first probably is not as
precise because of the ship c7 although
maybe it's still winning but King g4 is
probably better because then F Bishop c7
which is we probably although I'm not so
sure
so well he played king of two but maybe
he should try this and then what happens
here you get some end game like this and
then is this a winner as a draw still
could be a draw it could be i go 'i for
e3
yeah a43 wait can I go thinking yeah you
can go problems you can't go III because
of that famous you know this position
would be a draw because wrong-colored
yes one with the wrong color vision so
yeah actually because of this concept it
looks like I mean this could just be a
draw position
yeah actually I wanted to sacrifice the
a pond but maybe even if I go if or
first he goes King f2 instead of taking
the pond that's what happened in the
game similarly like oh oh you for for
Bishop takes but why do you think he
gave to the king of two still and
they're still drawn yeah yeah but even
this is probably still this one I'm not
king at stood Oh honking h2 yeah
yes I go around with my King King f5
kingi for king of five years
you can even coach e3 oh you can go yeah
you guys eat too but you can't I go et
tu f3m just
I have all my coupons you have two
points yeah just oh wait yeah this is no
this is somehow losing them I in zoobank
somehow oh wow we have this should be a
wow I can be in subspace here still way
too loose yeah so you have to be a good
precise but yeah g4 looks like a drawers
he done g3 yeah and if he goes then
there you can just yeah get a bloke
after once the Kings on have to yeah but
yeah you still have to these lines show
you still have to be very careful
but king of to looks like in precise
yeah
the ship d3 Bishop c74 III in e1 and
then maybe in jingchou one looks like it
still draws I mean this is the position
basically case Bishop c4 Bishop c5
Bishop takes d5 and the same thing yell
but he played King he want but I'm
curious though yeah so takes on takes
takes take on a7 King g3 but you don't
have to take on a7 though you you can go
be sure before prophylaxis against King
game 3
yeah because Bishop e7 King g3 I felt
I'm very close to winning this like this
actually is a winning yeah this actually
is winning here yeah I thought that this
is very good just to show the fans how
this position is winning you know you go
back this should be 7 then you go
[ __ ] 6 and then you go king around
somehow like this and then f3 f2 yep
what Qing Yi Qing yuan was played and
that was the decisive mistake now
there's no time so go king of 1 anymore
because of King G 3 3 and after this
King G 3 was you know very good I'm
wondering if this does not win Bishop
takes yeah
kingi to yes this does not win king g3
so King g3 was very precise maybe
costume is that from far away and now
this is ready winning because after this
you just go Bishop before very nice
fineness and then f3 and now if you
takes you go up to and after this you go
Bishop check
so you got the job done and then very
nice win you know keeping the tension
keeping the tension keeping attention
and that's what we got to do when we
need to win and eventually very often
opponent cracks especially if opponent
is a little bit in in that form so now
you're still half point ahead of Jackson
bully ugh going into the last round
who is your last round opponent morandi
dangerous once so not having the best
tournament but he did win today and
always the very dangerous opponents so
you know should be a very interesting
game tomorrow and I'm looking forward to
seeing the you know the crunch time
tomorrow wish you best of luck best of
i-10 looking forward to seeing some more
great shots from you thank you thanks
for coming
alright so that was Dennis Boras with us
with another impressive win against the
Dow a person who was having a very tough
tournament but still always very
dangerous Casa Corley yeah and now we're
gonna take a look quickly at JJ's game
JJ's game just finished we saw against
Brandon Jacobson so JJ's have been
having a little bit of a difficult
tournament but now he just won a very
nice fighting game against Brandon
Jacobson and it started off very quietly
but then it was anything but quiet there
was a lot of fireworks in this game and
you know let's see where were the more
main critical moments well anyway we
don't have to wait long we have a change
here with us in the studio how do you
want to be called JJ or JJ right okay so
we have JJ in the studio so JJ how do
you feel about those games of crazy
fighting game right yeah I mean it was
all pieces were on the board at the
beginning I decided to play b3 on the
first move because I know my opponents
playing g6 lately so I'm like I'll just
play b3 and
let's get a some once just for my
position just a fighting game with old
pieces on the board in the middle game I
think where do you think were the some
of the main critical moments in this
game I think I started miss playing when
I started playing like rookie to d1 I
don't know if I was playing like the
rest do you watch it should be still
good but I wasn't sure exactly how to
proceed it's of course a very flexible
position yeah yeah this was a relatively
kind of normal game right but maybe you
can take on d5 first right probably I
should actually decide on the structure
much earlier in the game rather than
keeping the tension yeah I didn't know
exactly what to do because when you put
the weight on the - he has a temple
maybe what that is right rooks are not
really doing much either so I placed
them in very natural squares but I
wasn't sure if they're even best place
so I was just moving yeah just the very
complex position very I think my
inaccuracy was Knight takes e4 it at
some point during the game after that I
think black god very easy play and so
you think rookie d1 was a knackered so
what do you think you should have done
here instead probably I should just wait
I was considering 92 but I was thinking
he can go like c4 is very unpleasant
yeah yeah I wasn't very happy about it
oh very nice b5 and then yeah they
should be c6 and I wasn't sure if I have
to actually go back or play Queen d3
yeah but maybe that was the best way to
keep the tension but it's of course very
hard to play like this it's uh yeah
complicated position but okay you played
and what doesn't look complicated but
it's like on the surface but it's
actually there are a lot of nuances
doesn't seem too bad actually rook e8
and it doesn't go together with 94
that's kind of what I'm maybe you should
play Roxy - exactly that's what my
opponent told me to keep just keep it
and just wait until someone decides to
break the structure yeah so you talked
and then you played 95 CD take
takes Edie and I did overlook III
actually I was not sure how to proceed
after III yeah III is of course an
unpleasant moves overlooked but it
doesn't seem like it such so costly
maybe actually was better to play a very
unconventional move take and play 95 and
yes go for 93 I'm not considering this
but I thought it's not so easy to give
up the dark squared Bishop and play like
this not easy yeah I mean even though
you get the d3 square it's still kind of
you know double-edged yeah although
White has no Knights and it's very hard
for black to really get this Bishop in
so it's kind of kind of logical putting
pressure on this but yeah III is also
very natural so yeah I think he just
wanted to play against my dog squared
bishop right yeah yeah the bishop on be
too exact here so and I'd see five
before Queen d7 King I'm not sure black
was like if black is actually much
better here but yeah well it's not clear
easy to play it's unclear if he's even
better at all yeah right I mean okay
your King is a weak but you do have an
extra pawn you do have the square for
the rook and maybe your Bishop is not as
Basile bad as it looks
yeah that's why I play d4 I thought I
have to do something with this Bishop
maybe Bishop c-123 but efore is very
natural of course I was expecting a rook
c4 he played b5 without even thinking I
was thinking like maybe b5 now maybe
life now yeah
also there's no interesting move h5 just
trying to put the King on 8 7 as well so
yeah but this is again a very very
subtle Bishop c1 Queen b6 Kim G 2 this
is all pretty good h5 rocked e6 Queen c7
Bishop e3 Quincy 323 and we're not sure
but I thought I was getting outplayed at
this point yes the Queen d3 is kind of a
way to bail out give up the pawn but
kind of centralize your pieces yeah and
I thought I also have potential takes
maybe on a 7 if I can take maybe h4 and
then if he goes here can play like here
stakes and if you actually go if I get
to this yes and you're better actually
so there's even hope to be better in
some end games if exactly Bishop's are
strong in end games if I can get the
right type yes Bishop d2 Roxy - I wasn't
sure what he is doing with the rookin
see - like it looks all good but I
didn't see how he breaks through no easy
follow yeah until I started becoming
over ambitious for no good reason here I
play route d7 which is probably fine but
my thought process wasn't I think the
right one Queens before I thought I can
simply take overlooking g5 and that's
where everything started to get yeah
yeah g5 is very yeah now it gets kind of
an ogre out of control so actually it
looks like a overall it was a very well
played game I mean it was a very complex
position but it didn't look like there
really any big mistakes right so these
until this point King age 2 would be
kind of an absolute keeping the tension
just because it's not much just there is
no threats exist one of these cat and
mouse positions you kind of just have to
running out of night at 4 check yes it's
kind of yeah exactly get out of foreign
you know both players kind of just have
to sit and wait yeah the thing is I took
on 87 without really thinking what he's
doing and once he played g5 I thought I
was in trouble yes no could be a
blundered here it's dr. King still does
king edge - right and then after this
there's yeah
Knight of fate I have to play room d8
apparently and yeah it's hard to see
that enough yeah my time was going low
and I panicked I took on g5 and I didn't
even realize Queens g5 is actually
winning a piece queen g5 is winning a
piece here incredibly enough here
updated - but yes amazingly he also
missed that he yeah he took on g5
without actually thinking at all once
again yeah it was probably one of these
he probably assumed he has at least that
but then he didn't check like if he has
something better
yeah so I guess something for him to
work on in this future react immediately
yeah but you know it's yeah I still kept
my calm and played King f1 Bishop e1 I
was playing with
but that's the only things I have to do
yeah and the few girls look up to then I
think that's the only move takes takes
is seven Queens III al and then takes at
least some sharpness seven is very
strong its but yeah I mean it's hard to
see all that in time here sure but yeah
it looks like he loves out there the
Queen goes to e4 and I said maybe I can
hold down
maybe he's thought he's surviving what
he must the magic queen a seven me miss
queen a seven yeah yeah because because
this Queen wasn't doing anything yeah
till the very last moves yeah and this
was you know collections easier than
breaking d5 you just really resigned
yeah because King you five Queen f6 yeah
bikini five Queen f6 yeah yeah then you
win the Queen on maybe even mate
probably if I I was able to take the
Queen probably
well actually just mate oh oh it's it's
made because the see three squares also
controlled but yeah very nice fighting
game I mean yeah I think the fighting
spirit was the most important at this
stage yeah but there were you know that
I'm not of many big mistakes besides you
know h-65 also yeah but certainly a very
complex game you know and so what square
are you at right now
numbers fifty percent so that was a nice
recovery and so more you have a chance
to play a spoilers role
yeah playing the leader that is morose
but I know I've played you on I was
white both times and I know how tough
you can be so I wish you the best of
fighting spirit convening you know the
good chests and continuing kind of from
the momentum from this game yeah I wish
you best of luck hopefully it'll be an
interesting game thanks a lot for coming
so with that I think this kind of you
know ends all the games for today so
once again diam section has been
finished so in the GM section we have
Dennis burrows leading after a very nice
win over Casa Corley Josh Tim Bullock
just behind him half a point behind
after another also very nice win against
let's hear from Brahimi on for whom that
loss was very costly so she'll have to
wait for the next tournament to get to
2,400 Justin Wang actually did manage to
survive a job from a very difficult
position so Andrew really miss played it
this part of the game for some reason he
did not play Bishop e4 and instead
played Bishop d5 and you took a draw
even though here he's completely winning
so but here this was a draw which
doesn't really help
Justin wank in his norm hunt he'll you
know definitely miss the norm because
he's only at five out of eight mm-hmm
and he needed six-and-a-half out of nine
but still he has a chance to finish out
a very respectable score he's guaranteed
a-plus score so still a very nice turn
for him and theoretically mathematically
he cannot win the tournament anymore but
can still fight for top three and now
we're gonna leave it to Ben Simon so
finish the recap
wow man are you tired yet Alex a little
bit hardest working man in chess I'll
say it again from yesterday it's nice to
see everybody again it's been like 45
minutes or so yeah but we this was been
a really entertaining show a lot of
really good in-depth analysis I've
enjoyed it's been a blast and it's only
gonna get better tomorrow before we bow
out let's see in graphical form if we
can see our standings for the
grandmaster norm section we knew the
situation for B before we knew the
situation for a group a that is we have
Dennis barouche and Jack certain Billy
ACK the two players who will be
competing
who can outperform the other one
tomorrow shetan Bulli AK to win outright
we'll need to help perform Boros and we
might just have a playoff and then we'll
have some other entertaining games as
well but all eyes will be on the games
of those two players and as we just
heard from JJ Alomar on D the only
Grandmaster out of the finale situation
tomorrow he will be playing spoiler
perhaps against Bora
Jack will definitely be in his corner
let's take a look at the standings for
the I am norm section three players can
possibly walk away with the championship
tomorrow they are all international
masters the three original gatekeepers
at the top hey what a surprise
Eric Rosen seemed that he is not
counting his chickens before they hatch
as the saying goes for tomorrow as
things would really need to go in his
favor with Keaton Kira losing his game
for Rosen even have a chance and he had
to win but well well well Eric is
playing Keaton oh is that right yes
that's oh well nice that's good gee I
wonder what's gonna be the game of the
day tomorrow
awesome awesome stuff do we have the
pairings for tomorrow the final round of
play this is gonna be an important day
right now we know with no norms on the
line no rating thresholds to be crossed
we're gonna be looking at Danish Boros
versus Jay Jay a lemur on D as well as
Andrew Hong one of the two youngest
players actually the second youngest
player in the field 14 years old I
believe taking on Jackson in Puglia and
in the IM norm section the pairings for
tomorrow it all begins at 11:00 a.m.
Central Time
there it is at the very top Eric Rosen
vs. Keaton Kyra Eric has to win to force
a playoff and as well at the bottom Ezra
chambers versus Louise Torres and also
has to hope that the Louis Torres
doesn't win against Ezra shame yeah well
then he would leapfrog the entire game
yes and without right so all three can
still theoretically win the tournament
so basically Eric Rosen does not quite
have things completely in his control
because tourists could theoretically win
with black and last round but I would
say if he does you know managed to beat
Keaton he'll have no very fair chance
for a playoff tomorrow and we expect to
see you tomorrow at 2 p.m. at u.s. chess
champs calm remember the games start at
11:00 so we're coming on three hour
into the session and hopefully for the
sake of entertainment the fields have
not been decided but we will have the
winners and create here the desk
regardless of what happens before the
show and we will be here until the very
end and the end may include playoffs
if playoffs happen it will be 4 p.m.
Central Time will have an extended
broadcast so this show was produced by
the world's greatest production B team
Dani Machuca is the technical director
Isaac Krantz is graphics and audio Erick
Mosel was show design
Tammy Hyde is streaming the show and for
grand master Alexander Linderman my name
is Ben Simon until tomorrow the grand
finale
at 2 p.m. at us chess champs calm we say
so long from the show-me-state
[Music]
[Music]
you
you